let's talk about the difference between kefir
and kombucha tea which one is healthier well
kefir mostly is created from lactic acid bacteria
whereas kombucha is created more from acetic acid
bacteria so we have two separate bacterias that
are creating this end product now with lactic acid
bacteria we have that bacteria in our gut but we
don't have acetic acid bacteria because this type
of bacteria needs oxygen and there's not a lot
of oxygen inside our digestive system but we can
benefit from the byproduct of acetic acid bacteria
now when you hear the word acetic acid you
typically think vinegar which is true but acetic
acid is also the majority of acid in kombucha tea
so let's start with kefir okay and it has to
do with lactic acid that's generated from the
lactic acid bacteria which also has to do with
the same acid when you ferment vegetables like in
sauerkraut and kimchi so the benefit of kefir has
everything to do with the benefit of lactic acid
and the benefit of lactic acid bacteria so this
allows you to digest lactose a lot better lactose
is milk sugar it helps with regular bowel
movements and especially to avoid getting
constipated it also helps fight against pathogens
it decreases inflammation it increases the immune
system especially against colds and the flu
it even can help prevent colon cancer and
the formation of polyps in the in the colon and it
can actually help you lose weight all right that's
on the kefir side where you have lactic acid and
lactic acid bacteria all right let's switch over
to kombucha tea which is really the benefit of
acetic acid not the bacteria because we can't grow
acetic acid bacteria in our guts all right
so this acid helps with your blood sugars
and it really helps to make insulin more sensitive
and with that comes a lot of different benefits
it will help you lower blood pressure it reduces
inflammation it helps you digest just from the
standpoint of adding an acid to your system
it helps to decrease the growth of pathogens
and it can increase mineral absorption
now just as an interesting side now
sour dough bread uses both the lactic acid
bacteria and the acetic acid bacteria which i'm
not recommending but i just wanted to let you
know so which one is uh healthier well that's
a hard decision because both of them have their
unique benefits so if you're enjoying my content
which i hope you are and you're applying this
knowledge to your health and you have a success
i would really appreciate you sharing your
success story so click the link down below
to my website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire others